dans la parole et à notre collègue
michel forissier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre
quasiment tous les indicateurs de la
délinquance présenté en octobre dernier
sont à la hausse au terme du premier
bilan dressé par le nouveau service
statistique ministériel de sécurité
intérieure depuis juin dernier le
gouvernement a pris l'initiative de ne
plus transmettre au maire le rapport
mensuel des chiffres de la délinquance
qui étaient adressées par les services
de l'état aux communes qui en faisait la
demande
la commune de béziers 2 je suis maire
comme de nombreuses communes de france a
mis en place en 2003 un conseil local de
sécurité prévention de la délinquance et
en dix ans la délinquance a diminué de
plus de 25%
preuve que la coordination locale de
sécurité a toute sa place
cependant sans stastistiques par commune
sans statistiques par zoom dans une
commune le pilotage par les maires d'une
telle instance perd de son efficacité
monsieur le ministre quel est l'objectif
de votre gouvernement quand il prend la
décision de ne plus communiquer au maire
les chiffres de la délinquance locale
vous répondre la parole et à jean marie
le guen secrétaire d'état en charge des
relations avec le parlement nous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur forissier jeu au prix d'abord
de bien vouloir excuser l'absence du
ministre de l'intérieur qui est retenu à
londres avec une dans une réunion avec
ses homologues consacrée à la lutte
contre le terrorisme la réforme des
outils statistiques de la délinquance
constatée par les services de police et
de gendarmerie permettra à monsieur le
sénateur de disposer de données
améliorées et transparentes afin de
mieux piloter l'action des services et
de mieux informer les pouvoirs publics
nos concitoyens les parlementaires et
les élus locaux
cette réforme repose sur une double
exigence mais je m'adresse aussi à vous
bien que ministre une exigence de
rigueur avec la création d'un service
statistique ministériel de la sécurité
intérieure labellisés par l'autorité de
la statistique publique avec pour but de
garantir la sincérité et la fiabilité la
robustesse de la production de ces
chiffres une exigence donc de fiabilité
et de précision par la mise en oeuvre de
nouveaux outils informatiques de
rédaction des plaintes dans la police
comme dans la gendarmerie
ce retraitement scientifique des séries
selon les méthodes de l'insee permet
désormais de disposer de données
comparables dans le temps avec une
fiabilité je le disais c'est les
standards de la statistique publique
il s'agit donc à l'avenir d'avoir les
chiffres de la délinquance qui seront
tout aussi rigoureux que les
statistiques économiques celle du
chômage dont et nous disposerons enfin
des outils nécessaires à la conduite et
au contrôle des politiques de sécurité
cette réforme a entraîné très
provisoirement la non communication des
chiffres de la délinquance
mais bientôt monsieur le sénateur ces
indicateurs vous seront communiqués y
compris au niveau territorial bien mon
cher collègue pour répondre au ministre
pour 50 secondes
merci monsieur le ministre de votre
théorie sur la statistique mais
permettez moi d'ajouter que le fait de
masquer les fibres la délinquance au
plan local pose problème ou moment où au
niveau national on annonce des chiffres
en hausse
et entre autres un bond de plus de 10%
des vols avec arme
ce n'est pas cette politique qu'on
qualifiait autrefois de l'autruche ce
qui conduit les responsables publics à
prendre les actions nécessaires sur le
terrain au niveau communal
l'absence de transparence est source
d'inquiétude pour nos administrés
l'opacité des chiffres vont encore
augmenter les craintes et cette perte de
confiance se retrouve dans les
consultations électorales
si vos nouveaux outils statistiques
doivent conduire à moins de capacités
d'analysé au niveau local vous priver
les mères
de levier d'action contre la délinquance
nous avons besoin de transparence de
chiffres précis et surtout il ne
conclurait par là d'une politique pénale
efficace merci